ce texte il prolonge jusqu'au 1er avril
2021 la possibilité de restreindre les
déplacements les rassemblements ou
encore de fermer des établissements là
où le virus du convive 19 circulent
toujours ce texte il est initialement
entrer en vigueur le 11 juillet dernier
au sortir de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et devait initialement courir jusqu'au
30 octobre prochain mais la dégradation
des indicateurs sanitaires à pousser le
gouvernement à revoir sa copie et a
conservé à cet arsenal législatif
pendant les six prochains mois après le
30 octobre prochain je vous propose
d'écouter gabriela talent le porte
parole du gouvernement
ce conseil des ministres a aussi été
l'occasion d'examiner si texte si texte
dont beaucoup ont des conséquences très
concrètes pour nos concitoyens je vais
revenir rapidement sur ces textes et je
pourrai répondre à des questions et
éventuellement le premier d'entre eux
c'est le projet de loi qui proroge le
régime transitoire qui a été instituée à
la sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
vous vous en souvenez à la sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le 9 juillet dernier la france est
entrée dans une période transitoire qui
permet de prendre vite des décisions
adaptées pour combattre l'épidémie
ce régime transitoire devait prendre fin
le 30 octobre 2020 le 30 octobre
prochain et compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire que vous connaissez il est
nécessaire d'anticiper de nous donner
tous les outils pour continuer à
combattre l'épidémie lutter contre le
virus et donc prolonger la période
transitoire sera prolongé jusqu'au 1er
avril 2021 il le projet de loi prévoit
un certain nombre de mesures en ce sens
notez que ce texte sera examiné à
l'assemblée nationale à partir du 1er
octobre prochain